we had this tweet from England Brewery I
have to because we talked about the
Music Cafe presented by Yingling having
an all ages drag show loud babies and
we're big fans of Yingling and so we
were concerned we were like saying so so
you're not sponsoring a drag show that
allows babies well Yingling has
responded they said
yingli has been a supporter of Art's
quest for many years along with over 300
local community supporters we're proud
to be part of their efforts to
revitalize an industrial neighborhood in
Bethlehem PA through our Arts Quest
sponsorship we have naming rights to the
Music Fest Cafe presented by Yingling
venue artsquest independently plans the
events and policies that take place at
this venue and all of their other
performance areas Yingling actively
promotes responsible drinking for
patrons 21 years of age and older we are
working to align with artsquest
regarding appropriate age restrictions
for venues associated with our
sponsorship we support their decision to
restrict attendance to 18 plus for the
June 30th show for more information
contact info artsquest.org that my
friends is how you handle it this I do
not care about a drag show at all I am
concerned that they that the slippery
slope it persists as such that we got to
the point where they're like let's have
a you know gay burlesque shows but allow
children and babies and
even if Yingling didn't know the amount
was happening they put their name on
this so Yingling what do they do I would
I would make this assumption this is
what it seems to me it seems like
Yingling seeing the response reached out
to them and said guys it's got to be
adults only and got them to do it and
that is exactly what should have
happened I'm I'm remarkable as I'm
massively impressed I'm gonna go buy
more Yingling this was fantastic just
keep it for adults we absolutely
such a common sense thing also that is
yeah so hey so you're an alcohol
Pavilion so it's 21 up let's just call
it it like this was an enormous relief
to me because Yingling is the only beer
I know to order at bars because they're
vaguely conservative and I know how to
say their name I thought although
someone yesterday told me it was
youngling I don't know thank you the
bartender is always yeah I don't believe
it but I I think this is a nice
statement partially because it's so calm
like we don't need to make a big
statement in either direction we say
this is alcohol it's inappropriate leave
it at that and again I I feel similarly
to Tim
I don't care what you're doing you know
in appropriately set age groups right I
don't think children should be at
directions but if you want to drive to
at a bar that's fine it shouldn't be
harder for an 18 year old to get into a
bar than to get or like a 17 year old to
get into a bar than to get into a drag
show right like it is weird to me that
we would suddenly toke away this line
but of course we saw it happening with
all of these uh drag queen story hours
there became this idea that in some way
this culture was acceptable to have in a
family setting but we ultimately all
know it's not and I don't understand why
this is the hill that this movement is
dying on
they can win it sorry go ahead there was
a story today
there was a story today in which Warner
Brothers Discovery sponsors outfest
which is a gay film festival and they're
having what's called
um celebration of queer children which
will include Story Hour and I and I
asked the question I said well I said
why is it that every time Disney hosts
one of these things or Disney throws
their hat in the ring and this everyone
goes up in arms but did you know that
Warner Brothers Discovery has a higher
ESG score than Disney why is it that
people don't care as much when Warner
Brothers Discovery does it but that's
because a lot of people think it's
because Disney is specifically geared
towards kids so it feels more predatory
and I'm gonna say I don't think anyone
could tell you what Warner's Brothers
does like yeah Disney is so much more
commercial it's much easier to attack as
a Target it's not okay
so so that is this is in the whole event
and they're going to have a whole
section that's dedicated to queer
children to celebrating queer children
to sexualizing children
well because if you think about it if
they again if they'll go after the most
extreme thing because if they can get
you to be okay with that what could they
not get you to be okay with I think that
that's the next step I always said it
like people used to call me crazy I'm
like the first thing you know about
someone if their body washes up on a
beach is their biological sex it's
undeniable no there is their age the
article recently where an archaeologist
said it's not good science I know did
you see that I saw that which is
absolutely crazy so how how far-fetched
is it to believe that the next thing
they say is well age is totally
self-identifiable too it's actually far
more subjective like there's 18 year
olds who act 25 there's 25 year olds who
act 18 on a much more obvious level than
you know you changing your biological
sex well there was a guy who tried to
legally change his age and they told him
no it's coming though I have to go back
to we should be pushing a culture that
isn't obsessed with looking at the self
the time right like if your kid you
think maybe Gay whatever how about you
ask them how are your math scores how
would you ask them what their hobbies
are how about you ask them literally
anything else instead of obsessing about
who they may or may may or may not want
to sleep with when they become
consenting adults like it's just bizarre
to me that parents feel the need to
become weirdly involved in their
children's sexuality when they are minor
teachers involved that's weirder but
this is the awfuls this is the affluent
white female liberals well you know what
it's become it's become just the it
started off with the slow obsession over
identity politics this is just an end
result of of hierarchical identity
politics if that's where your
hierarchies in society are generated
from because we're going to have
hierarchies no matter what you're going
to have a problem
um and again my buddy told me something
interesting one time when I was on this
Pathway to searching for religion he
said humans are designed to worship
they're always going to worship
something if they're not going to
worship something bigger than them
themselves they're going to worship
their job they're going to worship their
uh you know alcohol sex whatever that
thing is and right now we have a society
that is completely worshiping the very
thing you're talking about identity
uh and so we have an absolute religion
around transgenderism right now not even
not even LGB it's t we have a religion
around the t uh because we've completely
erased a lot of lesbians because now if
you're a lesbian Johns Hopkins
University yeah did you see JK Rowell
rolling trolling them over the the they
they disavowed it they said they didn't
mean to do anything wrong sure what
happened there I didn't hear John
Hopkins University had a glossary of
like different terms for sexuality and
gender and it said a lesbian was a
non-man who loves others a non-man
attracted attracted to I would say love
and that's really important yeah because
magnets are attracted to each other and
they're not men
but they left the term men in the
definition of gay and so you're just
erasing lesbians yes you are not a
racing gay men and JK Rowling you know
was like I think we should all talk
about this just the patriarchy
reasserting itself I have to wonder
right now you see the story about the
way to do it though how they made
embryos using stem cells recently yeah
like a day or two ago so I'm kind of
like
look
if they can make embryos using stem
cells
and they can grow farm animals in
plastic bags
how far away are we
from humans just no longer giving birth
yeah and they just say from now on like
I really do think there there is a
potential future if we lose this culture
War where there's going to be like two
you know 35 year old women and one's
going to be like no
tell me you're you're not serious
unnatural birth you are going to destroy
your body that's already happening
C-sections are on the rise in the U.S
and I mean not even that they're going
to be like use a use a pseudo wound no
that's what I mean I'm arguing to your
point I think we are moving in that
direction already they are saying you
should not have a natural birth you
should always have there's always
reasons that doctors are pushing for
C-sections these days whether it be risk
whether it be oh well you know there
might be this issue or like this is just
more controlled we'll know when the
baby's coming and it's something that
people are becoming normalized to now
hold on hold on if we get to that point
and we are also very close to the
designer baby period China has already
had several stories about super soldier
program where they're genetically
modifying humans to make them more
resilient more robust stronger taller
Etc
if people then start going
to
they're doctors to plan for their babies
and the doctors outright say we no
longer need women to have babies
when people are choosing the traits for
their kids what is what is the the
reason they would choose a woman
I mean that sincerely I'm not saying
there isn't one I'm saying what do you
guys think they would say because I feel
like when it comes to strength height uh
social status and and this is coming
from the left perspective of patriarchy
parents are going to be like let's just
choose a boy so there are certain
obviously uh benefits to like women have
historically always been better at
certain things like creating communities
empathy and those things will still need
to exist in society of course but I
think in the short term you're going to
have parents being like very liberal
very leftist but going but we do know
the patriarch is real so let's not
subject a daughter to that let's let's
have a young boy there'll be quotas or
they'll have a girl who then they want
to transition to give away
extra step or we'll literally get to the
point where you just don't have
genitalia and you're just completely
non-binary and true non-binary maybe
maybe that one's a ways off but I I do
think the first step before that is you
will likely just see parents being like
boys are going to be easier let's just
deal with that we don't need to worry
about grandkids anymore I sort of think
the opposite I think there's so much
antipathy towards men that people are
more likely to be angry about uh having
male babies I've had people say to me
like oh I really wouldn't want to have a
boy like a boy are you kidding me like
there is a lot of anti-man sentiment
that starts when you're having a boy and
Fair Point it may go the other way it
may be parents being like we don't want
to make the patriarchy worse or provide
more toxic masculinity I think real
quick if they move in the direction of
only girls
there could be a potential future where
the planet is 97 female and the
scientists and the presidents and the
military they're like we need to find
men there's just no Y chromosomes
everywhere and then some genetic disease
will start impacting the population and
they'll be like where are the men and
then like guys will be like hiding in a
cave because they want to take their
genetics or something sci-fi movie how
about this playing Xbox in the cave
I would watch that so it's always like
the male patriarchy is oppressing us
women they're a Decay though of our like
I read there's a decay of the chromosome
I think it's Plastics
the testosterone is dropping sperm
counts dropping the chromosomes breaking
up I think it's Plastics also in terms
of electromagnetism yeah but also
surrounded by Wi-Fi and computer sorry
but in the terms of what we're talking
about with births uh and natural births
and stuff like that when you talk about
what we were talking about earlier which
is the worship of self we're seeing the
rise of surrogacy because they don't
want to actually have kids themselves
they want to pay somebody else to have
the kid for them so it's like no matter
what way you go you're not having a
natural birth at all and then we have
people coming out saying they're having
a harder time connecting with those kids
because they didn't actually pair bond
with them in the same way and that's on
the rise every bit as much and oddly
enough also only available to the super
wealthy or to the people that can afford
it the thing it bothers me so much that
people didn't realize it would be hard
to bond with children that you didn't
carry because we have had centuries of
adoption right like this this is
something that we are still doing there
are always children who need homes and
if you look into it for even a second
this is something everyone talks about
that you it's not not easy but you have
to build a bond with a child you adopt
at any age and the fact that we would be
so arrogant to be like well I
specifically paid for this child so of
course I'll love it and it'll love me
like yeah it's a designer it's like
you're saying it's a designer child you
go pick it it's like saying your dog
doesn't like you like you you I bought
this puppy why doesn't it like my house
it's crazy yep it's very scary when you
disconnect yourself completely from the
reality of your actions another thing
pushed by the media the the decay of
actually supporting families that bond
with each other right like I said chosen
family they want you to go and choose
your family based on uh whatever your
immutable characteristics are outside of
your biological connection to someone
else it's about what you look like or
who you have sex with that's what they
seem to think matters to people thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored Members Only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time